we're worse by Google supports many
cross-platform development options by
default such as phone notifications and
actions on Google but what if you want
to do more and tailor your experience
for the risk i'm hilum and i'll walk you
through the development options for iOS
a wearable operating system by google
for everyone before we begin it's
important to note that we're always by
Google is based on Android so many of
the things you know about Android
development such as the concept of
activity or services the use of Android
Serio or the distribution via the Google
Play Store should be familiar to you
there are three options if you want to
tailor your app for where OS where apps
watch faces and complication data
provider it's it's not an either/or
choice you can package one or more of
these within the same apk so let's
briefly go through them in turn aware
app is a good development option if the
users journey can function better on the
wrist rather than on the phone great
examples of this includes exercising
content less payment and messaging
creating a where app is just like
creating a mobile Android app with a few
enhancement for the wearable form factor
this includes Ryan screen support for
resource qualifiers of Ranga where
classes such as box insert layout in
addition for longer user interactions
such as shopping lists exercising or
travel apps where OS support ambient
mode which reduces battery use and
screen burned in another way to develop
for where OS is to create watch faces if
you're interested in creating beautiful
and functional time pieces this is for
you showing the time is one of the core
aspects of a watch and as a developer
you can bring your unique style rights
to the watch face by overriding the
ondraw method in the canvas watch face
service you can draw lines shapes or
render bitmaps through the campus
objects provided if you have created a
custom Android view before this should
be familiar to you what if your user
wanted more than just the time for
example what if they wanted the latest
news
the battery level or even the weather
being a connected device and with the
users permission where OS can supply
data from Google or other third-party
apps to your watch face these extra
pieces of information and known as
complications a traditional watch making
term describing areas of the watch face
that are showing information other than
a time watch face developers can take
advantage of the complications framework
to make their watch faces not just
beautiful but highly functional as well
lastly developers can choose to
implement a complication data provider
which allows the app to share data with
the watch face this is especially
suitable for apps that have key
information the user would like to see
on their watch face such as share prices
or weather information this is a great
way to dip your toe into where OS
development if you already have a mobile
app development of a complication data
provider is simple just think about a
one key piece of information you would
want to show the guests started creates
a complication provider service and
supply the data requested on demand you
can also ask the system to request an
update when new information becomes
available such as a new chat message or
a piece of breaking news to conserve
battery where OS may reduce the update
frequency a good rule of thumb is to
think of the complication update
intervals being on the order of minutes
rather than seconds as I said at the
beginning there are a number of
development options available on where
OS from cross-platform support for
notifications and actions on Google to
where applications watch faces and
complication data provider the choice is
yours
if you're looking to enhance your
existing mobile app create a
complication data provider is probably
the simplest way to get started just
follow this collab for more information
check out a where OS developer site
happy coding
[Music]